good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
it's good
uh-oh it's a wild Hank and he's go to
bombing me yesterday we were out to
dinner and I made a dumb face in a
photograph and everybody the table
decided it was go to bombing yeah guys
like load o bombing but he looked like a
goat - speaking of goats our first
question is would you rather fight one
john sized goat or three goat sized
John's I'd rather fight one John sighs -
go - you were crafty making you a goat
would make you easier to fight there
definitely goes bigger than you I don't
think so I think that I might be bigger
than any goat by weary there are there
ghosts bigger than my brother I'm not
sure I understand I don't understand
either let's go to the next question
what are your thoughts on goats and
sweaters oh you mean like where you have
a sweater and there's a goat on it no
goats in sweaters a sweater wearing a
goat I mean a goat wearing this one a
sweater wearing a goat is a fantastic
idea go to pretend your pupils but I
didn't know that do you know why there
are like horizontal rectangles which
probably means that they're trying to
look out and more peripheral vision I
want to know what that's like
I bet the oculus rift could like can
show me what it's like to be a goat do
you want to get another question yes
let's do another question how many
llamas is one goat worth can i just
pause real quick i could ask why all the
questions are about goats the thing is I
just asked four questions that are just
having to be a bunch about goats I also
asked them to ask questions Bunker's oh
I see your tweet goat questions
preferred who can do the best impression
of a goat you want to go first no I want
to go not at all I'm happy to lose a
bangle try ah that was so bad so they
sound like you've never even met a goat
you know what they sound like I got
perfect I thought through ah Hank I made
the Internet's number one video about
goat mating don't tell me I've never
seen a goat I've seen a goat do it and
then make that noise so
this is a question that I don't think
you'll find pretending difficult Hank
would you rather have a goat eat your
ear or would you rather eat a goat see
how is that you because it's like the
old question would you rather eat five
pinecones or poop one like as unpleasant
as it would be to eat five pinecones
obviously that's the better option I'd
rather eat a goat seer than any other
part of it go because you could take the
goat's ear and it would be fine not fine
how would you feel if you were earless I
noticed that you and I have different
iPhone passwords you know if you want to
ask another question you're gonna have
to log in John where does the word goat
come from oh I know that actually a
comfortable English what is your
favorite breed of goat brand brand of
goats breed I'm gonna go with the
american mountain goat I was gonna say
the mountain goats too which kind of man
who goes though Oh John darn you'll
probably if you had seven goats between
you what would you name them I would
like to have four of the goats that's
all that matters to me I would like to
make sure that if we have seven goats
between as I have before and you have
the three how about alternatively you
have all seven wait I've rethought my
answer but I would like to give you this
seven goats hard and took another guess
of your iPhone password I still didn't
get it go to corn or unit goat yeah so
we're talking about two different
animals but go to corn is a goat with
the unicorn horn the unit goat is a
unicorn with a goat head or as I like to
call it a horse and I'm gonna go with
the unica here is a non good question
for you Hannah what really gets your
goat quit awful people succeed hey thank
you so much for doing question Tuesday
happy birthday it's your birthday
yesterday but I say a birthday to that
guy I will see you on Friday and now
okay and we have to go cuz we're out of
tape so